your end yeah
every day when he gets home sawsakuja
inhales steam
with some eucalyptus oil added to it he
says
this helps reduce the mucus in his lungs
he believes coughing gets rid of germs
that could make him sick
with no word from zimbabwe's government
on when vaccines against covert 19 will
arrive
the businessman hopes alternative
therapies will protect him
yes doctor saying stealing is not good
even home remedies are not good but
i think it's up to you to see whether
you can use it or you know you cannot
use it but for me
it helps me a lot
zimbabwe is battling a second wave of
coronavirus infections
and the already struggling healthcare
sector is overwhelmed
some of those buried recently include
two cabinet ministers
a retired general and other high-profile
zimbabweans
the country of about 15 million people
has 84 working ventilators in public
hospitals
and just over 1 000 beds for covert 19
patients
in private and public institutions
that's according to the health ministry
public health care workers often go on
strike protesting against poor salaries
and the lack of personal protective
equipment and drugs
sometimes you find patients dying in
front of you
when you know what were you supposed to
do but you don't have any choice
there is no other resources
you know this patient needs a ventilator
but there are no ventilators
you really know these patients need
certain drugs
but you don't have to try and bring down
the infection rate
the government has extended a lockdown
by two more weeks
this includes a dusk to dawn curfew and
shutting
land borders non-essential businesses
will remain closed
until mid-february that includes closed
stores and mobile phone
repair shops only 10 percent of
government workers are allowed to work
from their offices
the rest are at home health officials
are investigating whether a more
infectious south african variant of the
virus is circulating in zimbabwe
fearing it may have entered when
thousands of citizens living in south
africa returned home
for the december holiday the world
health organization
says the south african variant has so
far been reported in five other african
countries
botswana zambia malawi the gambia and
kenya
and according to who new and more
contagious variants of kovan 19
are spreading across africa causing an
increase in infections
and deaths so sakushka tested positive
for covert last year
he says he survived despite getting
little help from hospitals
since then he's been using herbal home
remedies to try and boost his immune
system
doing everything he can not to get sick
again
harumatasa al jazeera